two california gas station managers are
changing the way americans view an often
forgotten community
cousins from fresno have become social
media stars for their
tick tock videos introducing local
homeless people
to the world and it's all for a good
cause vlad duchess joins us with this
incredible story vlad good morning again
hey so good morning the cousins stopped
in the middle of the hustle and bustle
of running their family business to talk
to us their videos about the homeless
who visit the store
are warming hearts everywhere they are
so popular the two men have collected
boxes and boxes of donations and money
to help pay their kindness forward you
know how many people heard your story
mike
2.5 million people no
way yes akramoson and mason aliquari
post tick tocks featuring homeless
customers at the tower gas
and mini mart in fresno chris i got 40
to spend in the store you got 40 you got
40
to spend inside the store yup grab
whatever you want the videos have more
than 39 million views
now the cousins and gas station managers
are social media sensations for their
kind acts towards those
who are normally overlooked i'm going to
be full we've got
all my nutrients how did this all begin
when did you decide to start
filming them and showing their stories
on tick-tock
just all fun and games at first and
eventually the followers wanted to get
to know everybody else a little better
the clips show their talents ain't no
sunshine
when she's gone and tribulations
but more importantly their humanity
people come in here and say how much
they appreciate
us but we just we just kind of say we're
doing our best and we're just trying to
get back to the community
people all over the world send packages
and
hundreds of dollars so osun and
aliquari's homeless neighbors can buy
food
and other necessities in the store hold
on i got something free
the viewers have even developed fan
favorites one of them is
phil a man who's been down on his luck
for eight years
viewers sent him clothes blankets and
even special notes
bill's a genuine guy just wants to help
every time he's here he's just asking
like oh
can i help you guys out with something
take out some trash he just wants to
talk and hang out
this came this came in for you and their
help is appreciated by their fans
on tick tock and in the store
so get this mason told me one day he was
struggling with his college physics
assignment and
chris who is homeless helped him break
down some of the complex
mathematical concepts it made him think
about these people's lives before they
became homeless
and the cousins hope their videos will
make others contemplate our shared
humanity
instead of shunning those in need you
can see more of their stories on
instagram at tower gas
videos all right i love that story vlad
there's that word again humanity
once you peel back the layers and get to
know people
look what you discover we need more of
this everywhere right now
that's what we need